[Music]
to our other top story tonight with no
winner Saturday night the Powerball
jackpot stands at a stat read one
billion dollars thank you for joining us
on this Halloween I'm Kirsten Joyce and
I'm Christian Gossett as well it's only
the second time in Powerball history the
jackpot has hit one billion bucks yes
Joshua peguero our newest reporter
joining us live now from the lotto store
in Prim where time is running out Joshua
yeah so far the line has gotten shorter
I want you to take a quick look at where
it currently stands it starts right next
to this building but earlier when we got
here around noon this line actually
snaked around this parking lot and
started behind this building now the
story of the lotto store in print does
not close until 5 PM so for South Valley
residents you still have time to buy a
ticket they also set up a booth on the
other side of this building where
there's something 20 Quick Pick tickets
as a way to kind of cut down in this
line now most of the folks I spoke to
were from Las Vegas and they say they're
in a giving mood if they win
I know it sounds crazy because hey I
don't know that the Lord actually tells
you to gamble I'm not a gambler I live
in Summerlin Nevada but I literally got
the two finger tap from the Holy Spirit
to go get this and if I win it I'm
giving it all away it would be great if
Las Vegas would have a lottery because
what we're doing everybody from Vegas is
coming here and we're supporting people
out of our jurisdiction
now if you if you do choose to stay in
the line and buy tickets you have two
options you can use one of these
machines right here or you can go
through a teller where you can pick your
numbers as well and you're able to buy
your tickets again this store closes at
5 00 PM reporting live in Prim Josh
bragero eight news now